hello and welcome to footnotes in which
I explore the most ravishing language
and ideas from the last week of Wired
first up today it's story time in a
wired business piece on the Kindle and
the publishing industry Ryan tape makes
mention of the great work 1001 nights so
there's the Sultan and his wife cheats
on him and what could be one of the
biggest over reactions in all of
literary history he decides he's going
to marry a new wife each day and kill
her he does this for three years but
then he marries a brilliant lady named
shaharazad a kind of woman my mother
would call a keeper and not just because
she has a very pretty name this first
night she tells the Sultan a story but
leaves it at a cliffhanger so he has no
choice but to keep her alive which is a
really bratty reason to spare somebody's
life shaharazad does this for 1001
nights eventually receiving a pardon and
changing her jerk of a husband into a
somewhat more redeemable human being who
nonetheless will probably never live
down that whole killing one thousand
wives thing these tales have everything
drug use violence heavy drinking sex and
even flatulence and a story called and
I'm not making this up the historic fart
oddly enough some of the most famous
stories in the collection such as
aladdin Ali Baba and Sinbad were snuck
in by translators so 1001 nights is in a
sense a collaboration between East and
West featuring universal truths such as
flatulence up next the most holy of
Grails the Holy Grail um I don't waste
any more of your time but I don't
suppose you could tell us where we might
find a young find a i am a i want a good
a girl as our most recent world's most
wired pic musician Luke fishbeck is sent
to seek the Holy Grail that is a true
connection to audiences and whence does
this relic derive the Holy Grail
actually started out
anything but well it was a Grail but it
wasn't really holy in the midst of the
Crusades a french writer produced a work
called Percival the story of the Grail
and while in the castle of the Fisher
King this Percival sees a procession
there are boys carrying a candelabra and
a man holding not a bloody Lance but a
lance bleeding on its own which might be
the most far-fetched murder defense in
all of literary history then comes a
very pretty lady who's holding a
magnificent growl or grail it's not a
chalice but a dish which sucks because
they're for principle could not drink
wine out of it that we never outwardly
complained about this the Grail only
became a chalice ten years later when
another Frenchman wrote a story
identifying it as the vessel that caught
Jesus's blood at the crucifixion Joseph
of Arimathea supposedly sent the Grail
to Britain and consequently the heroes
of British medieval literature are all
antsy in their pantsy for it these were
the Knights Aaron who wanted around
cracking skulls in saving women and
other serious business this was best
cataloged in Monty Python and the Holy
Grail itself every working of the 1001
nights tale his but a scratch
now stand aside worthy adversary tis but
a scratch a scratch your arms off now it
isn't well what's that then other Dwarfs
you not come on your pansy